المدن ،
هذه الأدغال الخرسانية بعيدة جدًا
عن الأطوال الوعرة للقديس أندروز
أو الممرات المشذبة في أوغوستا
الوطنية
ولكن مع استمرار السكان في التحرك
نحو البيئات الحضرية ، تعمل
ثقافات الجولف الفريدة على تطوير
مومباي الهند ، هذه المدينة المترامية الأطراف
هي موطن لحوالي 20 مليون
شخص
[موسيقى
] أعمل في نادي الغولف الرئاسي في بومباي
في مومباي ،
لقد أحببت الجولف منذ عام 1994. كنت أذهب
إلى المدرسة وكان هناك نادي غولف
في الجوار ،
لذا بمجرد مشاهدة اللعبة بانتظام ،
أصبحت رياضتي المفضلة
بعد ترك المدرسة و  العثور على
عمل كعلبة في نادي سوريش للغولف التابع لرئيس بومباي ،
وبدأ بعض زملائه
في تطوير شكلهم الخاص من الرياضة
في أوقات فراغهم
في عام 2000 ، بدأت لعبة الجولف في الأحياء الفقيرة
في ذلك الوقت لم يكن مسموحًا لي باللعب
داخل النادي  لذلك كنا نلعب في
الخارج حيث بدأ الجولف العشوائي بمضمار
يمر عبر
الشوارع الضيقة ومجموعة من
العوائق والأهداف.
إنها مهارة وإبداع
خاصة عندما تضع في اعتبارك
بعض المعدات المستخدمة ،
فنحن نجد ونجمع النفايات من
المباني ، على سبيل المثال ، هذه القبضة مصنوعة
من أنبوب أسطوانة نفايات ونحن نلائمها
مثل قبضة
حقيقية وهذه الزاوية نديرها بناءً على
زاوية الوجه التي
نريدها بعد ذلك نحول الكرة الحقيقية إلى
كرة بلاستيكية حتى لا
يتأذى الناس
في بلد حيث قواعد لعبة الكريكيت التي
تثير الاهتمام بلعبة الجولف
هي شغف لسوريش
جولف لا يحظى بشعبية في  الهند ولكن في
جميع أنحاء العالم
في الهند ، لا يلعبها الناس كثيرًا ،
فالجميع يحب لعبة الكريكيت هنا ،
وأعتقد أننا فعلنا شيئًا جيدًا
جلبنا اللعبة إلى الشوارع والناس
يحبونها أكثر اليوم
نتيجة لذلك
أصبح الوصول إلى الدورة المحلية أكثر سهولة
و  مع لعبة غولف الشوارع المتاحة على
عتبة الباب
، نجح سوريش في نقل
حبه للعبة إلى ابنته ،
اسمي وعمري ست سنوات
كانت تراني ألعب وتقول إنها
تريد ضرب الكرة أيضًا.
لقد أحببت ذلك كثيرًا لدرجة أنها الآن تلعب
دورها ،
فقد بدأت عندما كانت في الخامسة من عمرها
هنا لأنه لم يكن مسموحًا لنا باللعب
داخل النادي ، ولكن بعد ذلك انتشر مقطع فيديو
لآشبي ونتيجة
لذلك منحها النادي دخولها مجانًا حتى الآن
إنها تلعب هناك
وكذلك لاعبي المفضل هو تايجر وودز
عندما يلعب ، يسدد لقطات رائعة
لهذا السبب أحبه
بدعم من والدها
ومستوحى من النمر
أشمي لديه بعض الأحلام الكبيرة.
عالميًا يومًا
ما ستجعل النادي فخوراً يومًا
ما وستجعل اسم والدتها
وأبيها يتألقان أيضًا